a friend tommy ha also known as
eardrums take a or eardrum take a is a
surgical procedure to remove
fluid from the middle ear and restore
equal air pressure to both sides of the
eardrum the ear has three
main parts the
outer ear the middle ear
and the
inner ear the outer ear includes the
auricle that collects sound waves
and the ear canal that
carries sound waves to the eardrum
a very thin layer of tissue that
separates the outer ear from the middle
ear sound waves cause the eardrum to
vibrate what it  in turn vibrates three
very small bones in the middle ear
called the hammer
[Music]
young
and stirrup
what passes in sound vibrations
to the inner
ear the inner ear translates the vibrations
into electrical signals that are picked up
by the auditory nerve sent  to the
brain and interpreted as sound, this
complex process occurs instantaneously
and allows us to hear the sounds that
e occur around us
for the eardrum to vibrate properly
the air pressure in the middle ear
must be at the same pressure level as
the air outside the ear air enters
the middle ear through the
eustachian tube or auditory tube when you
yawn  and hear a small pop
the eustachian tube has carried an
air bubble into the middle ear to
equalize pressure a condition allergy
mass or enlarged adenoids can
block the eustachian tube
causing fluid to build up in the
middle ear the fluid prevents  the
eardrum vibrating properly blocks the
normal transmission of sound through
the middle ear and can cause
hearing loss in some instances the
fluid can become infected with
bacteria resulting in otitis media or
ear infection
the reasons for performing a mirin
goto mine  are the following drainage of
fluid trapped in the ear for more
than three months treatment of infection
Chronic hearing loss that does not improve with
antibiotics Restoration of
hearing loss caused by
fluid buildup Impairment of delays in
speech development in children due to
hearing loss or examination of
middle ear fluid for bacteria
prior to surgery an IV will be placed
intravenous in most cases
general anesthesia is used so that the
patient sleeps through the
procedure
the surgeon will make a small incision in
the eardrum using a scalpel or laser
to drain fluid from the middle ear in
many cases the surgeon will place a
tube  ventilation or pp tube
through the incision this small tube will
drain any fluid that accumulates
after surgery and allow
air to enter the middle ear to
help dry it out if necessary the
surgeon will repeat the procedure on the
opposite ear on  The entire procedure
takes between 30 and 60 minutes. The incision
in the eardrum will heal on its own.
therefore no stitches are required after
surgery the patient will go to the
recovery room for monitoring
children may become fussy
after the procedure they should be
encouraged to eat and drink as much as they
can tolerate if your child is in pain
avoid aspirin  and instead
used acetaminophen at an
age-specific dose if
pain relief is needed
otherwise the doctor may recommend
other options the tube
usually comes off on its own within
several months